le nouveau règlement fédéral sur les
carburants renouvelables entre rang
vigueur au Canada le 1er juillet
objectif obliger les fournisseurs de
carburant à réduire leurs émissions de
gaz à effet de serre ce règlement
nécessitera des investissements
importants pour les fournisseurs ce qui
entraînera une hausse du carburant pour
les automobilistes hausse de 17 centres
du litre d'essence en 2030 et de 16
centres pour le diesel selon le
directeur parlementaire du budget les
ménages affaiblent le revenu seront
davantage touchés par ce nouveau
règlement avec nous Yves Giroud ce soir
directeur parlementaire du budget qu'on
retrouve à Ottawa bonsoir Monsieur
Giroud bonsoir est-ce que vous
considérez que c'est une nouvelle taxe
sur l'essence qui va toucher finalement
tout le monde peu importe son revenu
mais c'est pas une taxe à proprement
parler c'est plutôt les conséquences
d'un règlement que le gouvernement a
décrété ou à plutôt décider d'imposer au
pétrolières donc au raffineries ainsi
qu'aux importateurs de carburant
l'essence et le diesel afin de s'assurer
que l'intensité en carbone de ses
carburants-là soit réduites d'ici à 2030
par l'inclusion par exemple de carburant
renouvelable dans les mélanges d'essence
et de diesel ainsi que par d'autres
technologies comme par exemple l'achat
de crédit ou encore la captation et la
séquestration des émissions de carbone
lors des de la production du cycle de
production de ces carburants donc c'est
pas à proprement parler une taxe mais ça
démontre que la réglementation a aussi
un coût vous calculez que pour les
ménages à faible revenu la hausse sera
puis on va le voir de 231 dollars c'est
à dire
0,62% de le revenu disponible contre
1008 dollars pour les personnes à hauts
revenus ce qui représente
0,35% de leur revenu est-ce que ça finit
par être sans l'appeler une taxe là un
coup qui est injuste ben c'est clair que
c'est un coût qui est régressif donc
bien que les montants ou plus élevé pour
les ménages aux revenus en proportion de
leurs revenus ça représente une plus
petite proportion de leurs revenus donc
c'est un incidence beaucoup plus
importantes ou proportionnellement plus
importantes sur les ménages à faible
revenu parce que évidemment une plus
grande proportion de leur dépense vont
aux dépenses relatives au transport ou
encore sont incluses de façon implicite
dans les biens les services qu'ils
achètent par la composante carburant
donc c'est un impact proportionnellement
plus élevé pour les ménages à faible
revenu ce qu'on appelle un impact
régressif alors ça c'est le calcul que
vous faites le ministre de
l'Environnement Steven Guilbaud a dit
que votre analyse adopte une approche de
modélisation qui est déséquilibrée qui
ne tient pas compte de l'évolution
technologique et que vous
omettez systématiquement et je le cite
de prendre en compte les coûts
croissants des changements climatiques
les avantages économiques d'investir
dans l'économie plus propre est-ce que
vous êtes d'accord avec son propos
c'est clair que quand on estime le coût
d'une mesure
par définition on inclut les coûts cela
étant dit le gouvernement habituellement
ne se gêne pas pour vanter les mérites
de ses propres politiques ce qu'on voit
par contre c'est que de temps en temps
on a tendance à passer sous silence les
coûts ou à ne pas en parler autant que
ce serait nécessaire ce que un rapport
comme celui que j'ai déposé plutôt cette
semaine indique c'est que même en cas de
réglementation il y a des coûts et ces
couleurs vont être supportés par les
ménages le gouvernement peut bien
entendu vanter les mérites et mentionner
les avantages mais c'est important aussi
d'avoir les deux côtés de la médaille il
y a des avantages à avoir des règlements
qui minimisent ou qui réduisent
l'intensité en carbone mais c'est
règlement là ont aussi des coûts dans un
tweet sur Twitter c'est l'ex-conseillé
de Justin Trudeau Gérald Batz qui est
allé encore plus clairement à votre
endroit vous a traité carrément
d'incompétent il dit que votre rapport
ni aux discussions sur les politiques en
matière de changement climatique comme
si vous ne preniez pas en compte les
bénéfices économiques de ces mesures il
y a deux côtés à la médaille vous dites
mais il y a des bénéfices économiques
également qui sont associés à cela
n'est-ce pas
sûrement mais les ministres et l'ancien
conseiller du Premier ministre font
référence à des avancées technologiques
qu'on n'a pas encore vu donc peut-être
que les règlements vont donner lieu à
des avancées technologiques mais il y a
absolument rien de certains en matière
d'avancée technologique on peut respirer
que avec l'imposition de règlement il va
y avoir des améliorations technologiques
qui vont réduire leur coûts mais c'est
relativement peu probable dans une
période courte comme entre maintenant et
2030 que les avancées technologiques
soient-elles et répandue à un point tel
que les coûts des règlements vont être
abaissés de façon signe donc votre
estimation monsieur Giroud vous la
faites avec ce que vous avez autrement
dit mais en fait on l'a fait avec les
données qui nous ont été fournies par le
gouvernement du Canada donc c'est les
données même du gouvernement qui font
ma question dans le fond est-ce que ça
finit par donner une étude ou un rapport
ou une estimation qui est en bout de
ligne incomplète au contraire je pense
que c'est une estimation qui est
complète qui implique les coûts complets
de la réglementation les bénéfices vont
probablement ou les avantages s'il y en
a on va les voir probablement bien après
2030 par l'entremise du développement de
nouvelles technologies mais les coûts
vont être immédiats s'il y avait pas de
coût pour la mise en oeuvre de ces
règlements-là les raffineries et les
producteurs les importateurs de produits
pétroliers Fred déjà appelé technologies
là donc c'est parce que ces technologies
là dont auquel le ministre fait
référence n'existe pas encore ou sont
pas encore rentables pour qu'il y ait
des coûts selon même la vue du ministère
de l'Environnement et des changements
climatiques et vous de votre côté donc
vous êtes à l'aise avec l'estimation
vous avez faite est-ce que vous pourriez
revoir votre code d'anal sur des
questions comme celle-là qui touche les
changements climatiques si le
gouvernement des nouvelles données qui
veut partager avec mon bureau ça va nous
faire plaisir de mettre à jour notre
analyse mais elle a été effectuée avec
les données même du gouvernement donc je
suis totalement confiant que cette étude
là est solide et représente fidèlement
les coûts de la mise en œuvre des
règlements si le gouvernement a d'autres
données qu'on n'a pas encore reçu ça va
me faire plaisir de les considérer le
message est clair monsieur Giroud merci
d'avoir été avec nous ça me fait plaisir
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI